el ex presidente francés nicolas sarkozy
se presentará este lunes delante de los
jueces del tribunal de parís sarkozy
presidente de francia de 2007 a 2012
junto con su abogados y serán juzgados
por corrupción y tráfico de influencias
en síntesis es acusado de tratar de
obtener información clasificada de un
juez conocido como el caso de las
escuchas los sucesos se produjeron
durante una investigación para examinar
si el difunto líder libio moamar gadafi
había financiado la exitosa campaña de
sarkozy para la presidencia en 2007
no hay un documento no hay una foto ni
una cuenta ni una prueba material solo
está el odio el barro la mediocridad la
malicia y la calumnia smart beyond y la
caru que mientras los investigadores
analizaban una serie de grabaciones
telefónicas sobre el caso de lydia
comenzaron a sospechar que sacudiã había
ofrecido a un juez un ascenso a cambio
de información sobre otra investigación
en la que se alegaba que sarkozy había
aceptado pagos
de la heredera de l'oréal liliane
bettencourt para la misma campaña
política
en su defensa los abogados de sarkozy
han argumentado anteriormente que los
magistrados que investigaban la presunta
financiación libia se excedieron en sus
facultades alegando una pesca del río
revuelto al intervenir sus
conversaciones entre septiembre de 2013
y marzo de 2014 violando el privilegio
abogado cliente aunque sarkozy ha sido
absuelto de las acusaciones de veto q
tanto él como su abogado aún se
enfrentan a un máximo de 10 años de
prisión y una serie de multas